we are all anxious for stranger things 5
to come out more anxious than I'm
willing to admit so let's do a deep dive
into every piece of information out
there I've got some tea about release
dates time jumps and a juicy teaser for
the first shadow that might give us all
some major clues for what's to come we
love to see it it's not like we wouldn't
wait though there was a three-year gap
between Seasons three and four and we
all ate that up with a staggering 7.2
billion minutes of stream time within
the first week of its release but since
they already have an outcome for the
series they're thinking they should be
able to get everything done a lot faster
they were actually supposed to start
filming in May 2023 preferably trying to
shoot seasons four and five back to back
but the writers strike put everything on
hold for the time being The Duffer
brothers are also in support of the
strike Finn wolfhard did hint That
season 5 will probably come out sometime
in late 2024 with this cheeky quote by
the time it comes out I'll be 22 I think
I will be able to drink with Gayton and
Caleb and Noah at the premiere of
stranger things 5. his birthday is in
December so we'll have to see what
happens
speak in a Time gaps the these actors
are aging The Duffer Brothers have to
address it in the most logical way a
Time jump they did speak out about it
and confirm it was inevitable as part of
the upcoming narrative I'm sure we will
do a time Jump ideally we'd have shot
season four and five back to back but
there was just no feasible way to do
that ideally because season four and
five are so connected it would have been
great to shoot them back to back because
the actors would be the same age but
because that's not possible they'll have
to write that change into the narrative
the only thing that won't be included in
the time Jump will be the upside down
it's stuck on the day that will was
brought there that's a huge plot point
of season five which brings me to my
next Point these two are going to be a
huge focus in the new season we're gonna
dive into Will's Coming of Age story
might we get a love interest for him
there's been a lot of speculation around
how he identifies I'm wondering if The
Duffer brothers are gonna bring that to
light for us and Max well she's in a
coma and that wasn't written as a cheat
or a cop-out and season 4 on a
cliffhanger singer it's vital to the
plot the gang is going to have to stop
vechna once and for all and Max yes
player in that and will with his
mysterious connection with acna and the
upside down is also part of the Arsenal
any theories leave it in the comment
section for me now we know the Duffer
brothers are huge fans of 80s movies
it's no surprise that Terminator is high
up there on their list of faves in
season 3 the Russian antagonist was a
huge reference to Terminator he had the
cropped haircut the boots the staccato
speak and the Hawkins mayor even
referenced to him it's Arnold
Schwarzenegger my point to all of this
is that it's been confirmed that Linda
Hamilton so much the Sarah Connor from
the Terminator movies is joining the
cast of stranger things she's obviously
a huge fan of the series I don't know
how to be a fan girl and an actress at
the same time speaking of new cast
members we're also getting a new
director on deck for one of the episodes
he's most known for 10 Cloverfield Lane
and prey I'm talking of course about Dan
Trachtenberg if you haven't seen either
of those movies oh you should maybe you
recognize his name from the the episode
of Black Mirror that he directed or the
pilot of the boys basically what I'm
trying to say is with The Duffer
brothers and Dan we're in good hands
here okay this right here really
exciting stuff first off I've always
been a fan of animation and apparently
so have The Duffer Brothers It's been a
dream of theirs to create some sort of
Saturday morning cartoon Vibe for a long
time now and guess what we're getting it
they're creating a new animated series
it doesn't have a title yet that's set
in The Stranger Things universe and not
only that but they also have an idea for
a spin-off that only Finn wolfhard
guessed the plot of correctly Matt and
Ross have confirmed they have an idea
but not much else anyone have any
theories we do have an idea for a
spin-off that we're super excited about
but we haven't told anybody the idea yet
much less written it it hasn't even been
fully confirmed if they've pitched it to
Netflix yet we think everyone including
Netflix will be surprised when they hear
the concept because it's very very
different and for everyone who lives in
the UK there's a stage play premiering
in London called the first Shadow
there's a teaser trailer for it that
supposedly has some hints for what's to
come in the upcoming season who's
excited
I hate to say it but this deep dive only
made me more impatient for stranger
things to come back but knowing that Max
is still going to be around we're
finally going to learn about Will's tie
to the upside down and that we've got
some fresh stranger things spin-off
content in the works I guess I can
survive what are you most excited to see